before we go uh would it be possible to
play a round of the final five with you
yes okay okay good um all right well it
is time with sabrina carpenter for the
final five
all right
best thumb to clean to
nine to five
yes
yeah
yeah okay um who would you love to do a
collab with ah oh my goodness uh
maybe bruno mars oh bruno mars have you
ever seen him on saturday night live and
he does the pandora station where he has
to be like 15 different musical acts
yeah it's one of the great things crazy
um
okay if you were not a singer you would
be oh uh
a casting director maybe
i think that'd be so fun i know hear me
out though like watching everyone's
interpretation of the same thing but
they're completely different i've just
always wanted to know what that's like
why is your jaw still i love that answer
it's so unexpected and it's funny joseph
gordon levitt was on this show and a
casting director changed his life
because he was kind to him you know you
put yourself out there it's very
uncomfortable yeah
um okay an instrument you would love to
play in this man i would love to play
violin
there's it's just so cool or saxophone
you know well i could see you doing i
mean
okay i really want to make sure to bring
up um fast times which we've been
playing in the studio all day thank you
i've been watching the video um
obsessively which you are
so
um confident and
beautiful
and there's a very like action figure
cool
rock
star you you you have a tremendous
amount of
sensual confidence in it you're just
that means a lot from you i will say
like one of our main like references for
that video was i'm sure you could maybe
sense charlie's angel slightly yeah it
was absolutely i was just like i want
that i was like that looks great we
would never even come close but i think
you know kind of living in that world of
like kill bill
uh and you know
like tarantino like i just i think there
was that's a tarantino poster right
there totally yeah i love thank you that
frame it's so stunning and the whole
video is so beautiful thank you are you
excited about this song it's so good but
not to color it for you but how do you
feel about this
song i think it's just super
super indicative of the time i'm at in
my life and i think a time that everyone
has probably experienced i think the
last two years of my life there's a lot
thrown at me that i was just expected to
like already know how to process be
unfazed keep it moving when it was like
things that were really making an impact
on me and changing me as a person
so instead of kind of looking back on it
and
you know being unforgiving to myself and
kind of beating myself down for maybe
mistakes i'd made i was just like you
know this is just the time of my life
where
i am supposed to live i'm supposed to
make mistakes and then we also just
wanted to turn it into a really fun
dance song and take some 60s vibes and
make it something new so sabrina's
latest single and music video fast times
is out now everybody's talking about it
it's amazing and so are you
[Music]
you